[Music]
in h2no news submitted by Frank's redhot
a new study shows that water on most
major airlines is not safe so you're
going to die wait is it about the bottle
makes to its recycled with the bathroom
water oh God that blue water yeah cuz
like it's like mix the tap water and the
bathroom are it's all like kind of I
think I didn't stick into the bottle and
water is pretty safe
yep we're what the bottled water to
drink water in airplanes no I actually
always buy the bottle once I get through
TSA and I hate it because I always have
a bottle in my purse and then I'm like
[ __ ] I have to throw out this whole bowl
and then I go in and I buy another one
and it's so expensive eight bucks for
something like there's something
according to a 20-19 airline water study
released by diet detective calm and
Hunter College New York City Food Policy
Center at the universe whatever it's a
study what's good for you I feel reading
it oh my god so the study took it took
seven months to conduct and it
investigated onboard water quality of 11
major and 12 regional airlines and
ranked them accordingly
so Alaska Airlines and Allegiant had the
best water quality I like Alaska with
scores of three point three out of five
that's the bed yes and JetBlue and
Spirit Airlines had the worst no not my
jet blue blue two they're tying at the
bottom with water health scores of one
which I said it's a zero to five scale
what about my sweet virgin okay baby I'm
okay
oh no no you know that is Alaska so they
got the best yeah Virgin Airlines but a
virgin no I did not
I missed the dancing you know I missed
the dancing and like the whole rap that
they did I missed the whole thing
that thank [ __ ] well that this song it
was the song that got me are new people
that were in there like MADD Chadd was
in that video yeah
todrick yeah but it was just the song
got stuck in my head for too long you
know what Steve you know I think your
problem is what's that please I think
you just have this version that you wish
you could have done and if you didn't
wear that stupid wig to the audition you
probably would have booked it I didn't
go out for it and usually if I go out
for something odd book it we're trying
to be humble you're trying to be humble
I know that you went out for it you
cried about it Mickey told me about it
she let me bring it up I'm sorry Nicki
that I brought this up okay I tried to
hide all his feel there's that there's a
lot and they leak out you know like a
like a wet fart so what's what's the
last thing that you book says no and
always oh gosh like an audition
I've never booked anything at all ever
you probably do like direct yet you do
no I'm just I'm so not cool wait what
you're mean you're mean I think she came
up to me first
listen I'm sorry that your dream died I
just said I didn't like the song what's
wrong with that don't make me write up
the story that you didn't cast your wife
or me in that movie I'm still mad I know
that that's where your thing so that's
why I haven't hit the button ahead and
you know I'm still [ __ ] with you I
know we're talking about what the name
of the institution it was some [ __ ]
I rose towards the water quality on that
movie that you didn't cast the scene do
you put throw and dig the entire is the
day already okay dude I am bulletproof
are you I am yeah okay did you audition
for that music video - I've been in more
music videos than Syd Wilder you
probably have yes you did a lot of extra
work I know I was featured feature did
you get water no I got to drink him but
I were just in
in every video got four other people
check it out
I want to check it out was it good yeah
really good song is really catching yeah
like what was it what did you guys do we
were her friends her best friends her
BFF without hard for you why I don't
know if your friends how you find of
course oh then it's easy yeah real
friends okay gosh I didn't know okay I'm
so glad know that we're not real friends
oh [ __ ] I feel like we could be more
like friendly with each other but
whatever it's fine
Steve hint I'll try no no no I don't
care about the guys I don't care about
the guys like we should start like a
group chat called like psychotic or
something can you start the group chat
just with a note notepad of all of your
ideas because I want to do all of them
oh my gosh I actually keep a running
list of my phone I want your group than
I did to be overwhelming to everyone
involved everything I do is overwhelming
that's so that when they hear about it
they're like oh this is stressful
they're like I missed where they do
about this water quality haunted so
that's the thing this study was saying
that there's not enough penalties for
people who are not meeting the standards
of the ADA a DWR which is aircraft
drinking water rule and they're saying
that a lot of these airlines tested
positive for u coli coliform and
water-supply samples and yeah so but I
always see them pouring out of like
bottles and stuff so okay so bottom line
here that you get out of this study is
do not take the coffee
don't take the tea don't take water that
does not come out of a bottle don't even
wash your hands or don't even brush your
teeth because some people brush your
teeth in though in an airplane we don't
use that water period instead of washing
your hands bring Hanson Senate your team
what about if T is boiled
isn't that Cho because like when I'm
watching Survivor they always boil the
water and that's pretty chill sure that
could be your logic but they're saying
like just stay awake stay awake as to
get to boiling but like a lot of times
in coffee and tea is
I have a travel tip for you guys so my
sister I don't know how she did it she's
like a miracle she travelled from she
didn't want to leave Amsterdam Amsterdam
to Italy with ecstasy in her [ __ ] and
if she can do that you might want to
consider storing water like before you
go through tsa you might you know find a
little like compact thing you know make
sure it's environmentally safe Capri
Suns in there yeah that's [ __ ]
inspiration yeah I think that would be
good also if you're trying to do your
makeup and it's really dark and like the
[ __ ] like shuts everything off oh
[ __ ] you my phone is working
the Lummi case when it's actually
charged is a great way to do your makeup
man piss off your neighbours do that I
thought you were going to say still do
be case could fit right up your ass what
you just said no and don't ecoli like I
respect that that's a thing and like
that wouldn't really like you know
safety first
yeah good point boys remember you often
inspirational you know any other travel
tip how much does she could she get up
there
yeah it exploded in her [ __ ] and felt
like half of it she got to save half of
it you say how do you keep that part out
of the sorry forget that that happens
like the living case can help you do
your makeup though oh yeah the drug
thing exploded her [ __ ] whatever what
does she start tripping fine yeah she
caught me she's like Sydney I'm in Italy
I'm gonna need you to come get me
oh my god just go on playing and just
scare my nose cuz I don't speak Italy
how many I think she had like three or
four and she's like your father
that's not gonna motivate me you know
that's not an incentive for me to be
like near California so yeah I'm going
no I choose with it some guy you know
like in the beginning and you're like
she was like 22 or whatever or 21
she was actually no I think she was
younger I think she was 19 cuz you only
do that dumb [ __ ] when you're like yeah
super super super yo so yeah she was
with some guy that they were fighting
and then they like stopped fighting for
however long she needed to recover and
then they start you know let me go again
you've started energy to fight I feel
like when you're that age don't you
about nothing yeah like now I'm so old
I'm like [ __ ] that like even responding
to a text message can seem aggressive
you know I'm like voice notes only
ecstasy it exploded in her [ __ ] could
be a book title I'm pretty compelling
stuff
I can't believe she got away with that
though cuz that's you shouldn't OD I am
that too
I know that woman has been through so
much like she's resilient she can still
drink under the table like she's this
little tiny thing oh my god she would be
so annoying if I brought her here
because she'd just be like soda mirror
and like [ __ ] you're crazier than I am
like I'm making you look crazy look
she's like the quiet one I'm the loud
one but I don't do as crazy and stuff as
this one so you'd never know like the
quiet ones you always have to be careful
for like what are you up to you know
silent and judging right yeah I don't
know where I was going with that
I'm totally forgot no I get it I think
just want to brag about your sister's
[ __ ] yeah honestly no I don't I don't
[ __ ] no you just wanted to say that
could hold a lot of stuff yeah no I'm
saying travel hack if you guys ever done
I can't guru competition Snuka hold more
is that like in your like kangaroos is
in your vagina yeah is her pouch I've
never done that I've done the Yanni egg
how the [ __ ] you guys not know this
owning a gym oh my go workout for your
[ __ ] I mean people we don't want to get
us wrong when I go to the gym I'm like
awesome one's always using though the
Yanni a back is a hogging it and you can
work out with it by the way that's
thinking a brilliant sketch just like a
workout for your [ __ ]
like you know you go to the gym to do
put garnier so oh my gosh my girlfriend
got one of them stuck I think I said
this before I don't know this story
makes me laugh she got one stuck up in
her [ __ ] in Thailand and she couldn't
they should go to the ER and they didn't
speak English so she's like trying to
get it out no
like to communicate with her what's
going on she kept getting wet cuz the
tongs that they used to like get it out
it kept slipping she was there for three
hours can you imagine what is she she's
the [ __ ] that loves spiritual retreats
and she's like I'm looking for myself
I'm like [ __ ] actually stay home and
like do the self work but she what
thinks she'll find herself all over the
planet and she thought she'd strengthen
her [ __ ] as well well the girls told
her that in the spiritual retreat oh my
gosh I use this amethyst whatever yani
egg and it's transformed my life or
whatever is she sticks to up there or
whatever [ __ ] yeah and then that she
couldn't get him out because usually
there's a string so there's the Luna
eggs like well I don't know they're
called eggs they're balls be like ones
like heavier than the other and you just
like even when you're like at your house
just doing the dishes or whatever you
put it in there and you tighten it up
but what does it do it helps you grip
like a kegel exercise uh-huh it forces
you to like hold it okay baby
we always said you know helps with your
lower abs like it gives you a really
good ab exercise just saying throwing it
out there well morning and what is
ecstasy doing there I got asked my
sister okay cool without iphone Leone
egg was gonna hold some [ __ ] like it's
like a locket for your [ __ ] all right
yeah it's like a extra purse I never
thought about it like that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]